je leur apporte à la rentrée pas de
doute il ne s'agit pas d'un loto mais
bel et bien de l'ultime étape du grand
débat cette conférence régionale
citoyenne rassemble un peu plus de 100
participants tirés au sort et pour
certains le hasard a vraiment bien fait
les choses
la veille avec mon épouse on se pose je
me pose la question comment on fait
prête pour être tiré au sort c'est pas
une invention et lendemain après-midi
sms comme quoi j'ai été tiré au sort et
si j'acceptais 2 j'ai tout de suite donc
vers mon interrogation large et toussus
dit oui à chaque table on identifie des
sujets clés selon la terminologie du
grand débat puis on élabore des pistes
d'action des pistes qui s'enrichissent
au contact des autres tables avant
d'être présenté à l'ensemble des
participants exemple comment faire en
sorte que les citoyens interviennent
dans les choix politiques de plus en
plus de référendum déjà et sur la base
de tirage au sort et bien que l'on fasse
partie un citoyen égale une voix lors
des décisions municipales des décisions
régionales des décisions du conseil
général voire pourquoi pas à l'assemblée
nationale une couverture de vie
universelle lutter contre la fraude
fiscale supprimer un échelon territorial
sur les quatre grands thèmes les
propositions des fils parmi les
participants certains tiennent à
rappeler dans quel contexte ce grand
débarras vu le jour je me dis que si et
gilet jaune est
n'avait pas engagé ce mouvement serait
pas là aujourd'hui et qu'on serait dans
un brouillard
voilà maintenant espérons qu'on ne soit
pas en fumée pour la suite et un défaut
de grands banquets ou deux chansons le
grand débat se termine par la
traditionnelle photo de famille